[Applause]
this has been the first year of my life
um since the sort of fall of 2019
into this fall is the first time that
i've actually found a tremendous amount
of happiness
and balance and i've been the exact
opposite
wrecking ball pendulum swinging back and
forth
into like debauchery or like wellness
that
i hated so much i'd go right back to the
debauchery
and will you talk about that because i i
really have been captivated
dude for the last few years i've been
like theming my years
so i had like the year of fun last year
i had the year of love
and then this year i'm like it's going
to be the year of health
because i turned 40 this year in march
and i never really focused on my health
which was probably obvious
um i was going all around the world jet
setting everywhere and eating
a ton of sugar that was kind of my
advice i have a very sweet tooth i love
desserts and i've tried
like so many women out there like i've
tried
little fads and diets and things before
and i'm like
i need to do a really holistic approach
this time
i think what i mainly suffer from was
emotional eating
and dealing with the stress of being
becoming famous
internationally and it like um there is
a lot of stressful stuff that comes with
it i guess my way of dealing with it was
just like
eating doughnuts um so i was like
working on the mental side of things of
why was i doing that why was i not
valuing myself and having
better self-worth um and then also on
the nutritional side
my diet was mainly all carbs it would be
delicious
but for my body type i needed to eat a
lot more protein
so i've lost true i think it's like 40
pounds
this year so far and i want to lose few
more
i mean i love i i love my curves and
stuff i don't think i'll ever go
um too skinny but um
i feel so much healthier and
and i think i don't know whether it's a
thing with ladies when you turn
40 i feel like i really come in into my
own now
and and not just with help but with my
career i feel
more in control and um i get to produce
movies now which which is amazing and
kind of have more control over
the content and so i just feel like i
don't know everything
seems to be coming together maybe i'm a
late bloomer or something
um but i'm slowly getting it together
i think it takes a lifetime and i'm so
excited about your facebook portal
journey i know you're talking to your
family on it
and yeah because like what are we gonna
do these holidays
i mean a lot of people i don't think
will be traveling so
with this smart camera like it feels
like you're there it really does
um and i'm not sure whether i'm gonna
get the chance to go back to australia
because we have really strict
quarantine laws and they lock you up in
a hotel right now
um for two weeks so um with me i'll just
be
probably be portaling my family um and
doing our like
regular holiday traditions just just
this way
and i hope your holidays are great what
a year we've had
so hopefully the holidays are amazing
for everybody
well i am wishing you the greatest and
happiest of holidays thank you
thank you thank you rebel for joining us
today
it is a pleasure thanks jude
thank you thank you thank you
you